maylis quelle est la réaction exacte du
kremlin suite à ce coup d'état militaire
au soudan
le kremlin se dit inquiet par la
situation actuelle au soudan est sou s
sa stabilisation le plus rapidement
possible dmitri peskov le porte parole
du président russe a appelé toutes les
parties à agir avec retenue écoutez
nous sommes bien sûr très occupé nous
aimerions évidemment que la situation
revienne sur la voie constitutionnelle
dès que possible
nous appelons bien entendu toutes les
parties à faire preuve de retenue en
effet le soudan est très important pour
nous en ce qui concerne le développement
de nos relations dans divers domaines et
nous observons très attentivement ce qui
s'y passe
concernant un éventuel soutien de moscou
à une des parties le porte-parole de la
présidence russe a souligné que les
soudanais devait régler eux mêmes la
situation un avis mis en exergue
également par la porte parole du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
l'écouté est une ingérence étrangère
massive dans les affaires intérieures de
la république à tous les niveaux a
conduit en pratique à une perte de
confiance dans les autorités de
transition chez les citoyens soudanais
ce qui a provoqué de nombreuses
manifestations et une instabilité
généralisée dans le pays y compris la
séparation de fait de plusieurs de ces
régions nous sommes convaincus que les
soudanais peuvent et doivent résoudre
par eux mêmes les problèmes internes et
déterminé le vecteur de développement
souverain de leur pays en fonction de
leurs intérêts nationaux
la fédération de russie continuera de
respecter le choix du peuple ami
soudanais et de lui apporter toute
l'assistance nécessaire
un peuple dont la détresse et de
désespoir ont été d'après la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe ignoré par
les autorités de transition et leurs
conseillers étrangers pour maria
zakharova les récents événements
témoignent de la crise grave qui touche
tous les domaines de la vie l'éthique et
économique dans le pays
et son jeu si qui le résultat logique de
la politique défaillante mener ces deux
dernières jeunes et au soudan
merci à mal les extraits pour toutes ces
informations en direct de moscou en
russie donc